Oooohh god, okay, good morning, John.
VidCon is happening.
I don't know how I'm going to make my video
this week.
I didn't prepare properly, so let's go do
this!
I just have time to go start rehearsing with
The Perfect Strangers.
And there's definitely, I don't have my hotel
key.
This is hard.
This is the battery for my phone, which is,
like, 4 or 5 times bigger than my phone because
it needs to be charged like 3 times, I'm not
wearing shoes.
That's not what elevators are supposed to
do.
This is the first person to ask me for a picture.
[Guy with camera] Okay.
Oh I don't have my pass yet, so I can't go
in there.
And I'm not even on the floor I wanna be on
yet.
What's that gonna be?
So I haven't gone on the escalator.
I realized I didn't have my badge, so I wasn't
allowed to go to any of the places that I
needed to go.
...the shirts...what were they doing up there?
[Dave] I couldn't get into the warehouse in
time.
Ohh.. *shudder sound*
That was Dave, our warehouse manager, and
also merch manager at VidCon.
Also writer for SciShow, and also a really
good friend of mine.
It's Michael Gardner.
[Michael] Hey!
Woo!
Who, how's, how you feelin'?
[Michael] Great!
This is Julie, sometimes I tweet about Julie.
[Julie] Hi!
This is who Julie is, she makes my life work.
[Julie] Most of the time.
The expo hall getting set up.
All the escalators are off.
This...this is Rob!
Waiting for me, outside the room.
[Rob] Hey!
*rehearsal music*
Rehearsal had to take a break for bean bag
mountain.
*rehearsal music*
Bury me in bean bags!
I don't wanna know about the world anymore!
It's too hard!
I'm like four bean bags down now.
Leaving rehearsal, Craig needs me.
Craig WheezyWaiter.
I don't know why he needs me for, what for,
but he does, so I'm gonna go find him.
[WheezyWaiter] I run off stage, I run out
of the convention center, and I'm in the desert,
running into the desert, which I already have
footage of.
I found John!
[John] Helloo!
Just by the way, my badge has higher clearance
than John's.
[John] To me, that represents progress.
Okay this is kind of moment of truth for me,
I haven't seen the stage or the arena yet
at all.
Wooaaahhh.
Okay, that's pretty cool.
I'm very thirsty but it's very difficult for
me to drink these drinks because I know how
much they cost, but I'm doing it anyway.
Our pillows are, apparently, semi-sentient.
This is what it looks like backstage at VidCon.
This is what my dad looks like.
Oh, things!
All the wires!
Is that Tyler?
[Tyler] It's Tyler Oakley!
Hi Tyler!
Hi, Troye!
This is the part where we talk about how we're
going to do what we're gonna do, figure out
what kind of mics we need, uh, Monica tells
us what to do, basically.
We rehearsed, and now John is off to do an
Ear Biscuit.
I need a moral of the story, what's the moral
of the story?
[John] The moral of the story is that your
ability to come up with new ideas and execute
them continues to astonish me.
Aww...
[John] but not in a good way really, more
in an overwhelmed way, so don't say awww.
Just checking out what's going on in the expo
hall now.
I just got a Ze hug.
Everything we're touring with fits in one
elevator.
This guy grabbed the drum that fell off the
cart.
Thank you.
Now I'm back in my hotel room, because I had
to grab my computer so that I can go do a
technical rehearsal, which is where your computer
into a thing and you see if your PowerPoint
presentation is going to work.
I think VidCon is mostly walking, for me.
This is a big room.
This is where I'm giving my Industry presentation.
Now I'm at a welcome party welcoming people
who came to help us out at VidCon.
Ahhhhh!
Sorry.
Just being excited.
Hey, everybody, it's Natalie Tran!
[Natalie] Oh are you filming?
Oh!
The first thing when you meet a new YouTuber
is you're like "You're not average height."
So I was like, you're super short and she
was like you're super tall.
[Natalie] You're so short yourself.
Yay, hey, Katherine's here.
[Katherine] (sigh) Yeah!
You made it!
Freaking Natalie Tran gave me TimTams; this
is the best thing.
Aheheheh...
That was the day before VidCon started.
John, I'll see you in the morning.